We were out and about running errands and needed an afternoon snack,
so we decided to get some tacos.
Lucky's favorite food,
and I'm slowly getting around to them.
So we placed our order and obviously also had to get a large horchata.
I've been craving these so much this pregnancy,
so we always get one.
Then when our food was done,
we brought it over to the table,
and I usually get an al pastor torta and then two al pastor tacos,
while lucky got two tortas,
three al pastor tacos,
and five steak tacos.
I don't know what it is with him and his limes,
but he uses so many limes and needs all the hot sauce he can get.
Need to eat mine while it's piping hot and the cheese is all melty.
It is so good,
you guys. Soft but crunchy bread and the savoriness of it.
Absolutely divine.
The horchata is perfect with it.
I don't know what it is with this specific brand of soda,
but every flavor I've tried,
I absolutely hated.
Had to add extra onion and cilantro to mine.
Tried it with the other salsa.
Also made lucky try mine,
so I always want him trying my food,
and he really liked it.
And then I finished off with my tacos
after lucky had been done for a very long time already,
I was craving this very specific lime and basil ice cream,
so we got that as well.
I couldn't Make up my mind.
So I tried at least five different flavors
and decided to go with strawberry,
lime and passion fruit.